Freak bitches and it's just because he got mauled.
It wasn't because skill wise he was commensurate and then when floyd came back
in the rematch,
he just barked his face off,
just fucked him up because he just wanted to let them know like,
look dude,
I barely took you seriously in that first fight.
Got Close,
but it only got close because like this sloppy bra.
And then you just put a skill clinic on them in the second fight.
Sacrifice wasn't even close.
I think that that's the only con,
but that's not how connor normally fight.
Sound like a swarming face.
First brawler type dude.
He's a guy who's like cautious about getting hit.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm thrilled about it,
but I'm also uh,
I,
I wish,
I wish.
I wish I knew more about your side of the tracks.
Well we don't know enough about connor because connor has never had a
professional boxing match,
you know,
and the thing is you see as striking,
but you only see striking when he's working on kicks and wrestling and all that
other shit.
What if he just kicked him?
Like would that,
I mean just to just do it,
just to let them know,
just to do it.
That'd be fucked up.
He fucked up,
but it would be hilarious.
Laughter.
You'd probably.
There's probably some stipulations in the contract.
Say you can't get them in an arm bar
or choke them.
I think just kicking him in the head and knock him out.
It would be worth losing all the money and then getting more money after that.
Imagine he would be a god folk hero.
If they got in close,
if they got any clothes and floyd was like sucking in Juke on the outside and he
threw a jab to cover up or left high kick and that left high kick.
Next,
I'm just.
Can you see floyd go limp and he would go limp.
He'd never been high kick like that.
Jesus.
That would be crazy because he didn't know it was coming.
He could clip on with it.
Like if you had no idea if you hit a kick behind a punch like fighter is a lot
of fighters do to like throw a punch.
Literally a cover your face.
So the kick is behind it already and then boom,
the kit comes like why your vision is already you're thinking about the next
punch and bang the kid glance and you get chaos happens all the time.
If he did that would be insane.
Would it be worth it?
It wouldn't be with fuck everything up because no one would ever trust another
fighter from mma to ever fight a boxer in a boxing match again,
because we've only had the.
The opposite happened really.
You know,
she,
she quit in a lot of people quit.
I worked search and rescue in Alaska and Denali for years in.
And you'd be amazed at how many people are just like done,
you know,
just lay down and they're done because they're not rational enough to know.
Like if I sit down and I just took this a little bitty nappy ain't getting back
up.
You're taking a snap and you're done.
Yeah.
I mean that's.
No,
no,
no.
Now I don't like that.
So that's a weird term.
But with hypothermia,
the interesting thing that happens is you get euphoric,
right?
You go through this stage of super cold,
super cold,
and your core temperature drops low enough to where you for year comes in.
So oftentimes it was saying people we would find our undressed,
so get hot.
You get warm so the gloves come off.
The hats come off the pants and unzipped and you know everybody's,
everybody's buck naked on the side of the mountain right before they die,
before they die.
So I mean,
not that I want to go out that way,
but I can think of worse way.
So it gets you for it apparently.
Wow.
Because we've also pull people back.
I've seen multiple times when we pulled people back and they discussed that,
they described it
and then we start rewarming there.
Frostbite and Shit's not right after that.
That hurts.
Frostbite is so horrible to look at it too.
It's just shoot this stuff we had to see and her fingers are still half half
fingers are off.
She sent me pictures.
She's missing fingers.
Missing tips.
Tips.
Yeah.
She's lucky.
Some of the Phalanges are going chopped up,
so they got her down.
They ended up hours and hours and hours and we're tracking and we're,
we're trying to talk to them.
They get her down to camp four.
Which does that track that you saw then?
The trickiest part as he'll tell you.
Because I can't tell you can't afford a camp three.
Yeah.
Can't afford to camp three.
And then camp three to camp two,
which they didn't even do.
They couldn't get.
They couldn't get to camp two,
which is straight on the LHOTSE lhotse face.
It's a,
it's about a 60 slash 60 degree ice face,
which is slick.
So when you're roping somebody down,
you know it,
it actually does provide,
you know,
less friction.
You can actually slide somebody down,
but you can't get going too fast,
you know.
So now you're at 25,
26,
27,000 feet.
You're 130 pounds,
125 pound shirt,
but you get to lower this 200 pound lady down.
Hard oxygen.
And these guys are working on right now.
She's 200 pounds.
Well,
she wasn't that big,
but you know,
with all our gear and all 160,
270 pounds worth of weight,
you know,
dead weight just lower down.
So we got her down,
we got her down to where we could go in with a helicopter and we picked her up
and took her back down to base camp and that was when the meeting took place
between her and her husband,
the tearful,
rejoicing.
And so the part you missed was the helicopter landed.
It couldn't land at camp two.
We weren't supposed to go up to 23,500,
which at the base of low t a crampon point.
Andrew got there and said,
I can only pick one of you.
And she looked at her husband and said,
you stay until he made his day and take the next helicopter out.
So we got her down and she looked at her husband and said,
you stayed like pitch.
You quit.
Well,
she was mad because he got left.
She was pissed off.
She was pissed that she got left,
but he couldn't have carried her.
Know that you're switching.
It depends,
there's ways looking at it both ways.
Somebody quit,
somebody gave up,
somebody said no,
I mean who knows,
but I'm sure that had to go sue through some deep ass therapy when they got
home.
Okay.
So I'm going to.
I'm going to fill in the gaps here.
So fast forward a nine or 10 months and dude,
husband has a,
he has a heart attack and died.
So he died.
I'm sorry I shouldn't be laughing.
That's Kinda fucked up.
It's fucked up.
But man,
you're going to everest and then you had.
I'm a little more of the,
you know,
the shandling,
tons and tons of paper until you're drowning and confused.
Shan Lane.
That's a sad one man.
Have Fun dude.
That was oh the best.
And I'm doing a documentary about him now for HBO and so the most fun part about
it is he always went to the comedy magic club and did stand up even in eras
where you didn't know he was doing it.
That's where I met him at the comedy Magic Club.
And how was,
he was great.
He just,
I mean it was like,
for me,
I was a huge fan of Larry Sanders show and Larry Sanders show.
That's where Paul Simms got to start the producer of news radio and so when I,
you know,
when I saw him,
I was like,
it was one of those ones like,
oh wow,
a,
that's actually garry shandling right there,
right there with Jed apatow.
It's right there.
It's a weird one.
And He,
and you know,
the comedy magical,
they tape every show since the eighties.
They have every show taped.
Yeah.
And I said,
can you give me the last 50 sets that Gary did?
The comedy Magic Club,
and this is Ito from the last few years,
and no one's ever seen any of these jokes except the people at those shows.
He didn't do them on TV.
He didn't do them on talk shows.
There was no special.
Some of the funniest jokes you ever heard.
Just him,
you know,
working on the craft.
How about be being so funny?
Yeah,
but he did a lot of notes.
He was a,
his discipline guy.
He was in the seventies.
He wrote so many jokes.
I found these binders,
hundreds and hundreds of jokes in every loose leaf binder,
like a guy sitting at a desk all day just crafting like two sentence.
Perfect jokes.
Yeah.
But there's like the balance,
right?
There's that.
There's crafting the perfect jokes and then there's just being able to be loose
and fun and hilarious.
Well,
he also used to go on stage with a,
just a setup and he wouldn't know the punchline and he would say the setup and
hope the punchline came,
which was pretty wild.
He,
um,
you know,
one of the,
one of the great things about doing a documentary as you get to ask people for
footage,
so Seinfeld gave me,
uh,
the dailies for Comedians in cars getting coffee when he interviewed Gary.
And then the people who made the movie comedian about Seinfeld gave me all the
dailies of a sequence that they only use 10 seconds of the documentary,
which was Gary and Jerry going to the comedy magic club and doing sets.
And also there that night as Neil and Chris Rock and there's 12 tapes.
It's all their performances.
And then their entire conversation for three hours hanging out backstage and it
is unbelievable the conversation,
how funny it is.
And uh,
there's a moment where Chris rock is doing the joke about how Nelson Mandela got
divorced,
that even Nelson Mandela,
after decades of being in prison,
he could survive that,
but he couldn't survive getting out and being married,
divorced immediately.
I forget how he worded it,
but there's a shot of shandling alone in a green room watching rock do this bit.
And as he's doing it,
Gary's saying what he,
what he's like,
he's guessing what the bit is as rock saying it,
but in all of Chris Rock and it's a,
it's a really beautiful moment.
And that's what the best part of doing this documentary is.
It just finding little magical moments that no one would ever see if you didn't
dig deep.